- Alright, Matthew.
- Yeah.
- Matthew,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from?
- I'm from Hayward,
California is where I grew up
for the first 12 years of my life.
And then, my parents moved us
to Castro Valley, California
because we were in somewhat of the ghetto
and wanted to go to a better neighborhood.
And so,
yeah, I mean,
growing up in the ghetto
I guess as the white boy,
there were, you know, it
wasn't anything too bad.
I mean, I guess like once
I got a knife pulled on me on a corner
when I was like nine years old.
I think I saw, I well, I
know I did, I don't think,
I saw a condom full of
jizz hanging from a tree
when I was like 10
and that was like probably the
first time I saw anything like that.
But, you know, it was just
like there's gangs and stuff
like a, a friend of my cousin got shot
like couple blocks down.
And so, around that time,
a couple of years later is
when we moved to Castro Valley
and that was somewhat
better, but when I got there,
it was more like.
I came from where I came from
and then I entered a more whitewashed area
and then it was like, instead
of being the white boy,
I was the,
the white boy that didn't fit in
because I didn't have the money like,
or the new items like everybody had,
or clothes or, you know,
electronics or whatever.
And so,
I remember just being a
teenager and getting older
I liked playing basketball,
but I was never good
enough to be on the team.
And it just kind of an
outcast trying to find myself
and in high school,
as a teenager,
I got more into music and stuff
and I got into metal
and punk and everything
and I guess
one year I remember.
It was summer school,
I remember there was a kid named Ben
that he wore like Converse,
you know high top Chuck Taylors
and he listened to Blink 182
and I liked Blink 182,
which I'm not by any means
saying that they're punk,
but, you know, when you're 15 years old
that's a, so, yeah I was
listening to stuff like that.
And I started getting more into that
and I started wearing
Chuck Taylors and stuff
and I remember the next year
Ben's like, "Oh, you're a poser".
And, you know, all of a sudden
it's like you're finding yourself
and trying to be an individual
and you're a poser so.
Yeah so,
high school, it was cool
and I mean, it was, there
were some, you know fights
with, you know, kids that
wanted to pick fights and stuff.
It was-
- [Mark] It sounds
like a pretty normal childhood.
- It was, it was, I mean,
I have some stories
- Except for the,
except for the being an
outcast everywhere you went.
- Yeah, alright.
No, but I I definitely have some stories.
When I was about 11 years old
there was a fall festival in Castro Valley
and this is when we
still lived in Hayward,
but my parents wanted to go
and just kind of like your wine
and arts and crafts festival.
So we go there and I'm being you know,
oh I want to go home, I'm bored, I'm bored
and my parents are having a good time.
They're drinking, they're drinking wine
they're having a good time.
And we're watching, you
know, some cover bands
some dad cover band and
they, they're getting progressively
drunker and, you know,
not to the point where
they're sloppy or crazy
but they're just having a good time.
And as a child, as a,
almost a teenager, you know
I'm getting embarrassed, which
who gives a shit, you know
like who cares what they're
doing and what I'm doing
like, but as an 11 year old being in that,
I, I have the sense that
everybody's watching us and that
all these people like I'm going to see
any of them for the rest of my life,
you know, at this age,
I wouldn't give a shit,
like I've gone to shows
and danced my ass off.
You know, I've been on acid,
I've been on mushrooms like that shows
like I don't care, but
anyway, so
I knock the wine glass out
of my dad's hand, I slap it.
This little brat, this stupid little jerk.
(laughs)
And that was it,
my dad instantly
went from
partying, happy, which
they didn't drink a lot.
They, you know, didn't have
any problems like that.
My dad does have anger issues,
never beat me or anything.
You know, I got spanked as a kid
and he definitely did a lot
of yelling, but, you know
we can go in more into that later.
But in this situation,
it was instant change,
the look on his face.
He was, I, I knew I, I fucked up big time
and my mom, it was like a
scared look on her face.
He said that he's like
get in the car, let's go.
And we got in the car and
he drove home probably
and I'm talking down residential streets.
This dude was, I mean, I
have a very vivid memory
and to have this memory as an 11 year old
and remember looking at the,
you know, miles per hour
it was 50 or 60 miles per hour
down residentials the whole way
and I was scared out of my,
eh, whatever I was scared.
And so we got home, he's just
screaming at me, you know
like I'm, I fucked up, and I did.
I totally understand.
I mean, I don't know if I, I mean
I would hope that if I had
a child and I was drinking
I would have the capacity not to, you know
do something like that, but who knows.
Um, so he's yelling and screaming.
At that point my mom, she's there drunk
and so she passes out on the bed.
Well, then my dad starts yelling at her
because she's passed out drunk
in front of her son,
and that's not what you're supposed to do
and all this stuff and I'm freaking out
like, I'm scared and so
I run in the bathroom.
I remember he like slammed the door open
and put like a hole in the wall.
And at that point, I, I was so scared
that I ran out of the house.
I ran to the neighbors
and I said, call the cops
my dad's drunk, he's freaking out.
(heavy sigh) They called the cops.
And my parents had to go to
Santa Rita Jail for the weekend.
Both of them, because you know
how cops are sometimes they,
it's not very rational it's,
and plus when you have
two really drunk people
they don't really trust
them or believe them
and so, yeah,
and I felt really bad.
And so-
- A little drama in your childhood.
- A little bit and I mean, I have always
I've never been good enough for my dad.
It's always there's, I, I just,
I can't do it.
I there's things in life that like
I worked at a print
shop and there was like
he wanted me to install
like lighting and all these things
and I'm like, well, I've never used
a electric drill or whatever
the hell it's called.
I've never used one of these before
and he's like minds blown
that I'm like, I'm 35 now
that I was like this 33 year old man
that didn't have these skills
which, I mean, whatever
people learn their own skills
and, but you know, the stereotype.
And he was Mr. Manly Man.
He was a stripper in his
twenties, like big buff dude
and that's whole, that's
a whole nother thing, but
so yeah I didn't learn certain things
and because my dad would
always say like, I'll do it
like you, I, I don't want
you to screw it up basically.
He wouldn't say that, you
know to my face, but yeah.
So there were different things like that.
I would get in trouble at school,
but nothing, you know,
it was stupid shit like
one time, like I pretended to stab the kid
with a pencil and that, you know
I like went like that
and that turned into,
oh he was gonna stab
me and I got suspended
or, you know telling that
I told the teacher one
time you're not my mom.
I don't have to listen
to you, shit like that.
Like, I wasn't, you know, going
and bringing a gun to school
or graffitiing all over the walls
or smoking pot in the bathroom, you know.
- So how far do you go in school?
- I, I did a little bit of college.
I only did one semester of college.
- And you, you've had jobs?
Do you have a job now?
- Mhm, Yep. Yeah.
I've done, I've done a lot.
I did, I was like, okay, in high school,
like 3.0 or whatever grade point average.
In college I was trying to major
in mass communications
because I knew people
at a local radio station
that had referred me
to this school and to this teacher,
I, I guess I'm kind of
one of those people that
I have underperformed
or had ruined my potential.
- So, so you're working currently?
You have a straight job?
- I do, I do a gig
through an app, right now.
I was working at a restaurant in December
and then they closed down indoor dining.
Which was fine because
we had outdoor dining
but then they closed that down.
And then it was like, I
was doing double the work
because of delivery, you know,
packing bags and all that shit.
And then getting paid, like,
I mean not half, but
half in tips
because people don't tip
the restaurant for delivery.
They tip the driver.
And so, not that that's
wrong, I don't really care.
I, I didn't, you know
it wasn't like, oh damn
it the economy's fucked
I'm gonna take a stand or something like.
Okay time to move on to something else.
And so I found this app
through Craigslist that does gigs
and you just pick a
shift and you pick time
and how much you get paid and you sign up.
And so I started working
at this warehouse and
it's sup- it's pretty easy.
Over time I've took on more responsibility
and they've made me like
shift lead and stuff.
And it's, it's,
it's alright.
It's not-
- But you, you, you'd consider
yourself a good employee?
- Oh (laughs) yeah, man.
It's frustrating because
like most of these people
90% of these people could give a shit
but that's what is the
problem with these gig apps.
I mean, there's multiple problems, but
that you're hiring people
that don't care at all.
They have no, they could give a shit
if they work hard or not.
And these people that are managing it,
they don't care either.
As long as the job's getting done,
they don't care how it gets done so
in terms of recognition
only, I mean I have a few close people
I talk to and we all
know that we're great.
And I mean, I guess that sounds conceited,
but we, I mean it's just the fact.
And so we talk and hang out
and we compliment each other
but there is only one person
that has come up to me
and said out of their way,
you know, like anything
and it wasn't a manager,
it was a guy that does boxes in the back
that I am 99% sure
is doing blow in the bathroom every day.
This dude flushes the
toilet every 10 seconds
and then is farting his ass off, like,
I've done coke, like I know the deal bro
like, you don't need to flush the toilet
like I can, I can hear you snorting it
and I'm not going to tell on you.
Like, but yeah, he, he
he said that and that
made me feel really good.
And I was like, I was like, wow
that's amazing that that person
like, thought to say that.
And he's actually really intelligent guy
I've heard him talking he's,
he's from the streets in Oakland.
And he's a tough dude or so he seems
he puts on the front, but
yeah, I like him, he's cool.
- So, so, so your, your drug.
- Oh yeah.
- Tell me about that, you use what?
- So, I use heroin, I smoke heroin.
- And how long has this been going on?
- So I started with oxycodone, roxies,
blues, thirties,
in 2012,
a little bit.
I was dabbling with that a little bit
and tar, black tar heroin.
I was working, doing vending machines.
I had that job for seven years.
- You were smoking?
- Mhm, Always, always I,
after doing coke for a couple of years,
I was sick of putting stuff up my nose
and I'm afraid of needles.
And I see, I've seen
what happens with that
which not saying that, oh
me smoking heroin is so much
better than injecting it
but it just seems, you know
but then again, I mean,
I smoke cigarettes.
I smoked that, I was smoking a ton of weed
which I barely smoke anymore, but I mean
it definitely affects my
breathing and affects my lungs.
And that's something I'm worried about
and that I would like to quit eventually.
I mean, I actually was
on methadone recently
but my work schedule made it to
where I couldn't get
to the clinic anymore.
Because for the first
three months you have to go
to the clinic every day.
That's part of the process
and I was doing fine.
Methadone's a little odd,
it's kind of, I don't know.
I mean obviously like if I could choose
and if heroin was legal
and didn't give me
breathing problems to smoke
I would choose heroin
any day over methadone
but because methadone is socially accepted
in the world and you're not smoking it
and ruining your lungs it's obviously
the better choice and it's cheaper.
It's easier on the pocket book.
And so, sorry,
back to the, the roxies.
This is, it was actually 2013,
it was shortly after I
quit the music thing.
The Vincent Gallo show,
I quit after that, I was done.
I was like, I'm the guy
putting up all the money,
all the time, all the effort.
Everybody's saying, great
job, man, keep it up.
But they're not the ones doing all that.
So I said, fuck it I'm not
doing this shit anymore.
And shortly after that
I had a best friend named Tiffany
that would come pick me up after work,
we would drink, we'd do coke,
we'd hang out all the time.
And one day she comes to pick me up
and Hey, blah, blah,
blah I'm dating this guy.
And he showed me these pills
and Oxycontin basically
this is back when the eighties,
the OC eighties were still around.
And for all the people out there that know
the ones you have to lick the coating off
and then, you know,
(coughs) excuse me.
So she showed up and,
and I, at that point in my life was
I was 27 and I was just
like sick of everything.
And it was like, might as
well join the 27 club, right?
Which if you don't know,
Jim Morrison, Janis Joplin,
Jimmy Hendrix, all those people
that died of like, you know
drug related deaths.
Anyway, I didn't really want to die
but I was just giving up.
And so I was like, fuck it I don't care.
Sure, let's do it.
And that was the biggest
mistake of my life.
Cause I fucking loved it
and everybody says, don't
do opiates, don't do heroin.
It's you're never going
to come back from it
and of course I didn't listen.
I have to try everything on my own.
And I mean, you know
my life isn't like Requiem for a Dream now
like I'm not going and doing
ass to ass for money, you know?
But I, yeah, I just,
I loved it and it, it,
people say, some people say
I saw other people just get the nods
and are kind of like
(moans groggily) you know
but it makes me like fucking boom, I'm me,
I'm myself, I'm happy,
I'm free, I'm energetic.
Like it's crazy.
It became, it became
what I wanted it to be
and it became what I needed it to be.
And that's crazy because it's like,
it's like it took my
it, it's a fucking crazy drug.
It's like, it took my brain over
and it just said like,
this is what you needed.
And like, this is the way it should be.
And so they're
like, there have been multiple times
that I've tried to quit on my own.
There has been periods of three months
where I've been able to quit.
When I moved to Arkansas,
I was able to quit for three months
especially I thought, well
shit, I'm going to Arkansas.
I'm not going to know anybody out there.
So there's no way I'm gonna,
you know, know about it.
- [Mark] So,
(tires squeal in the background)
your, your drug use has continued.
You're you're, you're still
- [Matthew] Yeah.
- [Mark] you're still using heroin today?
- [Matthew] Right, because yeah
I couldn't make the
methadone treatments anymore
and so I, I didn't want to get sick
and experience the withdrawals.
I've I tried to quit cold
turkey back in September
a few months ago, but I
got to day two or three,
day two the first time and I broke down
and said fuck it add
some straws with resin,
you know shake those up with some alcohol
and put that on the foil
and you got, your good.
- [Mark] But does, does
it affect your work?
- [Matthew] No, no, nobody has any idea.
Nobody, nobody (laughs)
I'm, it makes me better at work.
- [Mark] It almost sounds, it
makes you like it makes you
better.
- [Matthew] Makes me better!
- [Mark] I've heard
people tell me this about
crack cocaine that these
are A, ADHD people.
- [Matthew] Right, like maybe I have that.
People have said that
too and I don't know.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Matthew] Never been diagnosed.
- [Mark] I had people tell me
that crack does the opposite
what it does to most people.
- [Matthew] Hmm it just
makes them like fine?
Or it makes them slow?
- [Mark] It slows them
down, calms them down.
- [Matthew] Oh, Calms them down
because they're usually they can't focus.
Huh? Yeah.
- [Mark] I think these drugs
affect everyone different.
- [Matthew] Right, right, yeah.
No, I mean, it, it, unless
I start getting crazy
and doing too much, then it
can, it can kind of do it.
- [Mark] Has that happened?
- [Matthew] Yeah, because there was a time
where I was just like depressed
and like didn't care and everything.
And so I was just like, fuck
it and spending all my money
but now I've learned
that, that's not worth it
because then I get in too deep
and that the money is gonna run out
and so I just pace myself
and try not to do too much.
And you know, it sucks when
I'm home alone sometimes.
And I'm just bored because
then I'll just like take hits
because I'm bored.
- But, but, you,
you would consider yourself an addict?
- Yeah, oh yeah, every
day I do heroin every day,
all day, every day. (laughs)
- You wake up and?
- I wake up and smoke, cause I,
I hop out of bed, it's like,
I feel like I'm going to some huge event
like the fricking outside lands
festival's happening today
and I get to meet all the bands
just because I get to smoke.
Be like, it's crazy like. (laughs)
- But you find it, it
prepares you for your day.
It makes you, you sharp?
- Makes me happy.
It makes me, I'm energetic,
because I get out of bed
I'm like, (moans groggily) damn I need to.
And you know what? You
know what this sucks.
And this is making me very worried.
Besides the breathing thing is,
recently I've been waking
up and my hand is like numb.
And like, I also,
it might be carpal tunnel because
of what I'm doing at work.
So I'm trying to do exercises, but
I mean shit I don't know if it's
just has to do with the drugs, you know,
that's, that's scares me so.
And then I'm like fuck
I can't use a lighter.
(laughing) You know what I mean?
So, that really sucks.
But yeah, I, yeah.
- Have you, have you met other people
that are functional addicts like this?
- Kind of, but not like,
I mean the people that
I, there were like people
especially like when I was doing Oxy,
that was more of a,
so with Oxy sometimes
because Oxy was expensive
it was get like 30, $35 a pill sometimes
and heroin's way cheaper and
that's why I started doing it.
Because it gets you
higher and it's cheaper.
And so,
Oxy,
I would post, this is back
Craigslist made it to where you can't post
certain keywords now.
But back in the day
you used to be able to post
Roxy blue jeans, size 30.
And then that's how, you know
I would find dealers sometimes actually.
And I mean, walking around the tenderloin
like walking pill hill, I mean
I used to have to do it
sometimes and it sucked.
I mean, one time a guy
tried to uppercut me.
It was fucked up,
just because I wouldn't buy his pills
his shitty fucking fake
pills, like, sorry, dude.
Luckily you missed, I mean
I don't know what would've happened,
but I'm not that I'm some tough guy.
I'm not trying to sound like,
(tough guy voice) I would of beat his ass.
You know, I'm not like that, but I mean
I might've tried to, but
anyway,
I would meet people on Craigslist
because I would, I started to realize
and other people would
do this, I picked it up.
Like, if you sell the
pills to somebody else
and mark them up, or a
common thing, I would say,
if I knew they weren't
going to buy that many
is I'd say alright, just throw me a pill
or throw me a half, like,
that's when you were really desperate,
you'd say throw me a half a pill.
And then they would, and you know.
One time I did that, this girl
we were smoking in a bathroom
and she fucking got on the floor
and started smoothing
the foil out on the floor
of a dirty Jack in the Box bathroom
and I was like, I'm on the wall doing it,
you know, the wall is smooth too
and I was like, what are you doing?
And she was a little whoop!
You know, and I, she's like what?
(mumbles) fucking you
know, smoothing it out.
It was like, do it on the
wall, bathroom floors dirty.
And she's, she didn't
care, so yeah, whatever.
So I'd meet, I'd meet functional addicts,
somewhat, somewhat.
They were definitely eccentric.
They definitely had their things
and they weren't reliable.
- It sounds like you're
you're a case where
maybe your psychological makeup is?
- But nobody's going to listen to that.
You, you will, because you
understand, because you've talked
to so many people and you
pay attention and you care.
There are people out
there that have no concept
of this and don't want to hear it.
Cause that's the way the world is.
- Yeah, well, I'm open-minded but
- Yeah.
- I mean, I've never
smoked pot, so I don't, I don't
know anything about drugs.
The fact that I'm doing this channel,
- Nice.
- but seems
to revolve about drugs.
- Good for you.
- It really doesn't in my
mind, but it certainly has lots
of drug stories.
I don't even know how to spell marijuana.
(Mark laughs)
So, so, so, but I'm just open minded.
(Matthew laughs)
I find it interesting that it helps you.
- Yeah.
- I believe
- I find it interesting
that you never even smoked marijuana.
I mean, not that I'm
saying like, Oh, you should
or you should have, but
yeah, they need a channel
you know-
- I'm not better than anybody else, right?
- No, yeah right, Neither am I.
- I've got my own problems.
- I'm not saying, I'm not saying
I'm better than any other addict, you know
like, we all have our own things
and we're all, we're all unique.
We're, I mean, everybody
it's makes the world, the world
and sometimes it's the beauty of the world
that's the fucked up things.
- I think finding something that helps you
find fulfillment and
happiness is important.
And if that happens to be heroin
and you're and you've
got it under control,
maybe, maybe it's okay.
I don't know.
- I do but then it's the
money thing, you know it's-
- How much do you spend?
- It's a lot of money, I mean-
- What do you spend a week or?
- A month probably $1,500, so
I could have a nice apartment.
- $1500 a month?
- 1500 yeah.
Because they, I imagine I probably do
- And it's illegal
- 500, 500 a day.
(buzzer noise) Nope, 50 a day.
- It's illegal
so technically you could
end up in jail, right?
- Right, yup, yup.
So, yeah,
that sucks.
- But talking to you, looking at you
you don't look like the
typical heroin addict.
- And that's why I'm still probably here
and functioning and not
on the streets, you know,
because if, if it started
to affect me, I mean.
I don't know if I started smoking crack,
I probably would, I know a buddy-
- I can't count how many heroin addicts
I've talked to that just nodded off
in the middle of an interview.
- Right, they probably also shoot up, well
I guess people now,
I've known people at nod off
that smoke it, nevermind.
- Yeah.
Yeah, you know, it's, it's never happened,
except one time,
the worst story is
I was drunk and I went to my dealers RV
a guy that was living in an RV
and I, he,
he had terrible shit.
It wasn't doing anything for me.
And I was pissed.
And because I'd have to travel
like an hour and a half to this guy
and I was at that point,
this stupid, very stupid.
I said, you got to have something, right?
He goes, yeah, I have fentanyl.
And me knowing exactly what that is
and what could happen and everything,
was drunk and said, fuck it, I don't care.
Wind me up some or whatever.
I don't know how long later,
I wake up and I'm like,
where the fuck am I?
What, what happened, you know?
And everybody is around me,
scared out of their mind.
And I fucking OD'd man.
I fucking OD'd for the first time ever.
And that, that really,
that really upset me
because I didn't ever think
I'd get to that point.
But (sniffs) yeah, they had to hit me
with Narcan like five times they said,
and like every, they
said I was turning gray.
And like, like my, like only
only my girlfriend knows about this.
Like, nobody else knows about,
I mean probably just the
people that were there, but
phew, man I really tried
to quit after that, man.
I got through like a week.
(laughs) And I was happy,
but I was happy that I quit.
I was fucking bored out
of my mind, you know?
But yeah, that was, fentanyl is no good.
Don't do it, everybody
out there don't do it.
- Yeah, no fentanyl's
a very different game
than, than heroin.
- It's a fucking crazy game to play man.
That's a, yeah.
- That's a very common move
for a heroin addict too.
- Yeah, I do not want to do that at all.
And I know, and I know there is
some fentanyl in the black tar heroin.
- That's what I'm gonna say is that
very often they're lacing
it and they're mixing it.
- Luckily I have, you know-
- Even, even crystal meth or
crack, they'll do that with.
- Yeah, luckily I have a reliable-
- I mean, they can do that to anything.
I think some of the girls that work as,
that have pimps,
will smoke a joint
and the joint might be laced with
you know, crack or meth or
heroin or fentanyl or whatever.
And then they're addicted and then
they're, they're basically
a slave to the pimp.
- Yeah, I knew, I heard a story
about a guy once that smoked
a joint with some random dude.
He was lost in the middle of the night
in the snow in Chicago,
couldn't find his car.
And some dude says,
bro, I've seen you walk
by a few times, come in,
you know, you can stay.
And he seemed like a cool guy.
He's like, you want to smoke a joint?
The guy's like, oh yeah, I do.
I smoke weed, let's smoke.
Fucking smokes it,
it was laced with meth.
Dude starts jerking off in front of him
and fucking holds him captive overnight.
Wow!
I'm lucky, you know-
- You see the world you're involved in
by using this, this illicit narcotic is
- Yeah
- Problematic.
- Yeah, you know, totally.
And I, like I was saying
I have a reliable dealer that I trust,
but that doesn't mean anything,
you know, he could get something
that he doesn't know about
you know, but
I mean, at this point I'm really
just trying to make it through
until I get the next job
which should happen in a couple weeks.
And then I get a set
schedule and I can get back
to the methadone clinic
because I know, you know
I'm a smart-
- Can you say your
say your, your mind
works better on heroin?
- Mhm.
- Could you ever get clean and,
and still enjoy life to its fullest?
- I mean, I did before,
- You did.
- you know,
it's not like, it's not like before,
- It's probably a safer way to go.
- before I started, I
wasn't enjoying life.
I was just depressed in that moment
and I made a bad decision.
- Yeah.
- You know?
- So it sounds like getting
clean would be the best move.
- Oh, totally, yeah.
And I, I want to, I, I
and I didn't even want to do methadone
because I said I don't want
to replace an addiction with an addiction.
And my buddy's on methadone
and he tried to stop one day
and he said it was way worse than heroin.
So I know there's maintenance plans
where they can wean you
off slowly but surely
and I'm hoping that's what's gonna work.
If not, I, I've said this
to people I'm close to
and my girlfriend, like.
I think I just need to be
locked up somewhere, you know
like for 30 days,
because I am resourceful,
I'm it sucks.
I don't like lying
and I, I know that probably
sounds like bullshit,
I really don't.
But as an addict with
the world the way it is
and people, you know, would
look at me a certain way.
I have to lie because I, I need to get by
and just, yeah.
I was living with my
girlfriend's mom and her
for a couple of weeks.
And her mom had me pegged
from probably day two.
She told her, he's on drugs.
And I was with my girlfriend
for almost a year.
- How could she tell?
- She's smart, she, her
ex-husband was an addict.
She knew she's, she and
also is making, you know
longer trips to the bathroom
quite often, you know?
And I'd always like play YouTube videos.
I watch Soft White Underbelly, you know
in the bathroom while- (laughs)
- Everybody, everybody
that watches that channel-
- They're like what are
you doing in there?!
I'm watching the hillbillies shut up!
- They're all a bunch of drug
addicts watching that channel.
- Yeah, so, yup.
- Cool, Well story's amazing.
- That's it right?
- I wish you the best of luck and,
- Thank you, man.
- I like your open-minded
attitude about getting clean
- Yeah, thanks for the opportunity.
- about getting clean, not
about using heroin, right?
- Right, yeah, no.
- I, I don't condone
the heroin, use at all.
- Yeah, no right, no, I'm not.
I don't think so.
- Yeah, also I'm glad you're doing well.
- Thank you. Yeah.
- I wish you the best of luck, man.
- Right on.
- Thank you man.
- Thanks Mark.
I appreciate it.